when I go travel and speak to kids it's
about being authentic
it's about being myself and I talk about
if I get up on stage or I'm speaking at
a conference and I paint myself as
perfect the only message I'm sending to
those kids is they can't be anything
like me and I don't know what people
don't think I'm perfect I am working
progress but I want them to see that how
important that work in progress is and
it brings peace and so that's what I
hope to people that's what I hope people
see is Alton is working progress and
he's gonna use his horrible story to
make a difference and on the flip side
of that is I get to encounter some
amazing kids that are just as strong if
not stronger than I am and that's like
one of the greatest things in the entire
world boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sock young
very excited to be talking about the boy
who carried bricks we have Alan Carter
joining us on the show hello how are you
thanks so much for coming on out really
appreciate it glad to be here thank you
you Scout one of the coolest stories and
journeys that I've ever heard in my life
I'm really excited to be able to share
it with you guys
for those who don't know Alan's
background Alan Carter went from being
tossed between foster homes to a
director of youth ministries there's
multi award-winning books the boy who
carried bricks and Ageing now detail his
journey and courage and perseverance
with the help of countless people and
you can find his website link below Alan
Carter dotnet as well as his Twitter
profile and his book profiles as well
all right and before we get started so
Alan's background is so interesting and
his talks online about how he got to
where he is today I would love to start
by actually giving a synthesis of what
one of the talks that he gave online
about his journey so Alan's background
was abandoned by his father his mom was
addicted to prescription medicine he
have five brothers and sisters all with
different dads he was severely neglected
and under-resourced the Department of
Human Services came and the judge told
his mom you are
fit to be a mother you cannot have your
five children and that's when I knew
that he would never hear those words you
are unfit to be a father
after 17 foster homes three institutions
and going to the Boys Ranch where he had
punishments like having to pick up five
bricks lock them 40 yards and do that
over and over again for two hours he has
displayed this book title the boy who
carried bricks is a massive metaphor for
life God brought him love and light
through so many people along his journey
and at just the right times when he
needed it he was the first person in his
family to have graduated high school
then he dropped out of college spent
four years homeless in the streets then
he went back and graduated from Oklahoma
State University became a police officer
and then the director of youth
ministries he has two sons and three
adopted children with his wife and he's
the author of four books detailing his
journey and inspiring children two of
the siblings have died two are in and
out of prison and he currently speaks at
schools around the USA inspiring kids to
persevere this is one of the best
stories about being able to no matter
what the deck of cards that were dealt
is to be able to find the gifts in that
and to be able to share and inspire
other people around the world to see
that whoo all right let's start by
talking about how your journey ended up
being a gift for you
well perspective and so sometimes you
feel like it's a burden and this the
struggles that you go through tend to
tie you down and so like it's
interesting with the way the woohoo
carried bricks that for the longest time
honestly until I wrote the book it was
kind of a burden so I was successful in
life I mean I was providing for my
family I had a good job but internally I
had all these issues and it was coming
to this point of
of sharing my story that I realized that
talking about my childhood was a way for
me to turn it around to start letting go
of some of the issues that were hidden
inside that were crippling me and making
me self-doubt and be insecure and so to
me it was I didn't know what else to do
with my story instead of holding on to
it I thought well let's let's let's
share it with other people and so what I
hope is when I'm telling people my story
it motivates them it gives them courage
and and also they figure out that
they're not by themselves
now when throughout the process of going
through your life journey did it
register that these were gifts that all
on the other side of these traumas were
the greatest treasures hmm I think it's
a process and what I mean is I think
it's self-discovery and so it continues
that what what I found is that I'll go
I don't always tell my whole story
whenever I go speak at schools or
workshops or conferences but sometimes
I'll share different parts of my story
and it's amazing how it connects with
other people and so it's just constantly
evolving that for me that to figure out
that this that all these things that
happened to me are still revealing
themselves that are useful here's an
example like the Boys Ranch our ranch
dad was extremely abusive he made us
work like I mean hostages it was
horrible later on in life I figured out
when I started looking at my family and
seeing that most of them didn't have a
job that my ability to work hard came
from the Boys Ranch that our ranch that
exposed us to labor and I figured out
that I could work with my hands and so
it's just constant discovery
okay so it's a process of discovering
that what can sometimes be it feels like
a lesson but in many ways does it feels
like it's being disguised in some way
but that only later do we recognize it's
a lesson so maybe a good question would
be how do we more effectively realize
through our life journey that some of
the hardest things that happen to us are
the greatest lessons absolutely
so I I'd say this it is important to
have an internal dialogue with yourself
that you're having a constant
conversation with look at how this abuse
or this neglect or this trauma has
affected my life and then you figure out
what to do with it and so whether it's
go to therapy whether it's have
conversations whether it's get involved
in community service to me you have to
look at yourself you have to look to see
how things have affected you and to me
that's how I learned to turn it around I
was looking at how some of that stuff
was bothering me and I didn't want to
repeat it and so you know one of the
things I talk about is we repeat what we
don't repair and so it's important if
you're hurt and you don't want to give
that to the people you care about it's
important to heal and that's where that
turning it into a positive that you know
you look at two people who grow up in
the same household my dad who's an
alcoholic one of them becomes an
alcoholic and the other one it so part
of its choice but the one who chose not
to be an alcoholic he had that same
circumstance and he thought I'm not
gonna do this to my family and so that
was my motivation to take all that pain
and suffering and make sure that I did
not give it to my children yes whoa we
repeat what we don't repair that's a
really good one so we heal the cards
that are dealt to us
that need repair that that we need to
repair and if we do heal if we do do
those repairs then what we can do is
then not it almost promises us that we
don't repeat the mistakes and that our
children won't have those same mistakes
absolutely and you also here's the other
part you provide a blueprint for other
people to repeat that process what I
mean is one of the greatest teaching
tools even as parenting we want to tell
people what they should do to better
themselves how about this how about you
watch me heal myself then you know how
to do it and so that that's all part of
the process that by me going through all
this and not that I'm perfect you know I
talk about being unfinished I'm still
working progress but if people can see
me work on myself that's a blueprint or
that's a that gives people an
opportunity to to figure out how they
can heal as well okay so if we more
effectively were to have blueprints of
repair that we went through so for a
specific card of like a lesson or a
trauma that that we went through as
cha-cha as a child but different
blueprints for different healing
modalities let's say and then if all of
these blueprints for healing were made
available mm-hmm for people to learn
from and to see how we can most
effectively repair and heal and
integrate and love that part of us then
it would make it so that way less
repetitions of traumas and and
malevolent circumstances or hard
circumstances end up occurring that's a
cool way of looking at it so blueprints
of healing and then being able to kind
of take from different ones that other
people have succeeded from and make our
own company
yeah and and so people do well let me
say this what what I find or what I
found growing up VHS school teachers
counselors they did an amazing job at
teaching me how to take the acct
how to fill out an application how did
you know pay bills nobody told me how to
heal like nobody said hey Alton when you
turn 18 there's gonna be a large part of
you that wants to go back home now you
know it's destructive but you're gonna
want to go back home hey Alton nope
nobody told me hey what are you gonna
say nobody talked to me about what are
you gonna say when your family asked you
for money or how are you gonna deal with
the fact that you never got to meet your
dad nobody ever talked to me about those
things so you know and in life what we
want to do is we want to take make men
tough can't cry you can't show any
emotion and so what happens is you
suppress these childhood issues and so
two things happen either one they morph
into something else or you end up
repeating what was talked the other
option is you you know you deal with it
and work with it and so I that was a
struggle that I had when I got older was
trying to face all the millions of
issues that I felt like I unders all've
dish OU's the the blueprint for healing
if you've never met your dad yeah yeah
and so for me one of the struggles is I
knew what a dad shouldn't do so I
watched multiple men come in our house
and I guess you could say there were
father figures they looked they they
played that role in the house you know
they slept in the same bed with my mom
they were supposed to be the provider
but they weren't you know there are a
few of them that my mom tried to tell us
to call dad and so I I saw the pain and
suffering that they caused and that's
not what I wanted that's not what I
wanted and so a blueprint of that
sometimes you can get a negative you can
get a negative example and you know
that's not what you want to be and it
kind of causes a different aspect
because what it end up doing for me
making me like really insecure because I
didn't know I mean I knew what not to do
but I wasn't a hundred percent sure that
what I was doing was right and then now
what we call the so there's the
blueprint for healing and then there's
also this blueprint like you saw when
the judge said that your mother was
unfit to have the five children or like
when you saw that you had the different
men coming in the home that what would
we call that it's like a blueprint of
maybe of like avoidance or like what
would that be like my first thought
would be blueprint of choice of choice
because some people don't they don't
think they have a choice and we do we
have choices we have a choice I I made a
choice then that I was not gonna grow up
that way I don't think my brother made
that choice I don't think my sister ever
made that choice obviously and so that
first thought is this is what I'm gonna
choose to do and so the the great part
is that I did get to see examples later
on in life people model like my
father-in-law was a great husband so I
got to watch him interact with his wife
and so I got examples and then had a
couple of friends old you know later on
in life and so I had a choice I had a
choice and I didn't always make the
right choice but I learned that it was
up to me I liked viewing it as
blueprints of choice and then that we
get to choose from different healing
modalities we get to see how maybe like
some of your siblings maybe had the the
choice of seeing what blueprints they
could choose
had maybe more positive life
trajectories but there are these ruts
sometimes that they keep us in like you
said that if we don't repair we will
repeat and I just this has been a really
awesome start with analogies a light I
love these analogies these metaphors
they they can make circumstances in life
a lot more relatable let's talk about
how you've been sharing your gifts with
others you had this really good story to
us as it was an uncle Stewie Stevie
Stevie
uncle Stevie that that uncle Stevie had
had some abusive tendencies when you
guys were growing up with the it was
with the in your grandmother's home with
your grandfather and a couple uncles
three two three vehicles and uncle
Stevie um your this story of how you
were you would stop in the middle of the
road and Uncle Stevie would have you
guys go and ask people for money based
on like a needing help or going in
taking things from the Salvation I mean
pawning them or be having you forced to
drink whiskey and you said that that's
it I'm not drinking the whiskey and then
he threw you down the stairs
mm-hm and then that's when you said
that's enough and you called the the
police and then you had that moment
where the family was looking and and
making it making you seem like you were
a coward right but it was about
perspective because later on in life
people were saying you were a you had
the courage for doing that right and so
then how have you been sharing stories
like that perspective change and all
these other gifts with all the kids
you're speaking to and through your
books tell us about it so sharing
especially with that story what's
interesting is that up until I wrote the
book I never said that but I thought
that I was a coward I thought I left
my grandparents house because I was a
coward I didn't think I was strong
enough you know there's something wrong
if you abandon we'll save the tribe if
you leave the family that's like the
ultimate betrayal you know you just
didn't do that and so the fact that I
wasn't strong enough to handle it made
me feel less about myself and it was
actually at an assembly and I had an
elementary school kid told me that it
was courage no men treat elementary
school kids said that I said because I
said I kind of I finally came out of my
mouth I said I was a coward and his kid
said you're not a coward that took
courage and I was like you're right
you're right
and so for me like when I go travel and
speak to kids it's about being authentic
it's about being myself and I talk about
if I get up on stage or I'm speaking at
a conference and I paint myself as
perfect the only message I'm sending to
those kids is they can't be anything
like me and I don't know what people
don't think I'm perfect I am working
progress but I want them to see that how
important that work in progress is and
it brings peace and so that's what I
hope to people that's what I hope people
see is Alton is working progress and
he's gonna use his horrible story to
make a difference and on the flip side
of that is I get to encounter some
amazing kids that are just as strong if
not stronger than I am and that's like
one of the greatest things in the entire
world to hear a kid say hey you inspired
me or they'll share a poem or or
something like that with me that that
gives me hope so also what a what a just
that wave of viewing what like the the
ultimate thing that you can't do is
leave the family no matter what the
circumstances are but when does the
tipping point happen when it becomes too
abusive when you just have to leave and
you have a better life trajectory by
leaving and going on a journey
an adventure and and then coming back
and you you came back like you saved up
1,500 bucks and came back and gave tons
of presents at Christmas this was
another one of those perspective moments
of you coming back and delivering a
present for everyone in your family but
nobody having a present for you and you
remembered it as the Christmas word and
you got no presents but I think it was
your cousin that said that it was the
Christmas where you gave everyone
presents absolutely and so perspective
is everything so the the bad part about
that up until 2007 I mean I just got
depressed around Christmastime I mean I
really did I just two days before or two
days after Christmas I was in my room
feeling sorry for myself with my wife
you know wait for my wife and kids so I
participated in decorating the house and
putting the lights up and all that stuff
but for the other time I was just
depressed and when my cousin came over I
realized that I had grabbed the wrong
perspective now the consequence of
living in the wrong perspective is that
I robbed my wife and kids of the husband
and father they deserved because I was
looking at it and so sometimes our
negative or wrong perspective hurts and
not cripples but it sets other people
back because my kids didn't get the
father they needed especially around
Christmastime and so and again so
finding the right perspective is about
surrounding yourself or allowing
yourself to to hear from other people
and I love how you also described it as
being raw and authentic that you're not
portraying yourself as perfect but that
you are a work in progress that you're
unfinished and that then this the
students that you're speaking to are at
the conference people that you're
interacting with they get to also see
themselves in that light that I am also
unfinished and I'm also work in progress
and that these cards that have been
dealt to me that I have these blueprints
of choice to repair to heal and so that
it doesn't repeat oh this is getting
good
okay so then what about
then when you are presenting you're
sharing you sharing your gifts and
you're seeing maybe other Sue's uses
sometimes you said that they come by you
know
aha a hundred people come up to you
after you're done talking and they talk
to you about who they are and what
they're going through and how you're
inspiring them or what they're learning
tell us about some of those engagements
so there was one I was in Louisiana
speaking and I was telling my life story
and the whole time I'm talking there was
this teenage girl sixteen or seventeen
she's like getting frustrated and kind
of talking to herself as I'm telling my
life story and so after it was over when
I finished you know talking I started to
walk out of the gym and she got up and
met me halfway and I go can I help you
and she goes I don't believe a word you
said and I'm like what do you talk about
she goes I don't believe a word that
story was about you it's not true and I
go why would I make that up and her
response was because you turned out okay
and so I was kind of puzzled by that and
then after she left I asked the
counselor and the counselor explained to
me that that child's life that she had
never seen anybody make it out and so
that was foreign another encounter
probably one that I try not to get
emotional but I was speaking elementary
school again telling my life story and
kids will usually say because I don't
talk about my dad because you know I say
hey I don't have a father so one of the
kids said hey Alton what would you do if
you met your father and I said well you
know I don't know I don't know because I
wouldn't even know how to find him his
name's not on my birth certificate so
anyway they started taking questions a
few minutes later so the principal was
handing the microphone around and this
kid on the other side of the auditorium
instead of getting the microphone he
gets up and he walks to the front of the
stage and he grabs the microphone and
hen's the microphone he said I got
something to say about your dad and I
was like okay but he goes I just wanted
you to know your
dad missed out and so it was one of
those things that hearing that from a
kid I mean it was a sense of peace so I
talk and share my story hoping that I
can encounter people that are gonna I
mean it's a third grade fourth grade kid
poured that into me and and it just you
know and then you go to places where
kids will say hey I'm like you I don't
have a dad or hey I'm like you you know
I was in a foster home I was speaking at
a school one time so I'm also dyslexic
and so I was speaking and when I told
the elementary school kids that I was
dyslexic this kid stood up and said I'm
Dyslexic - so he's a fourth grader and
behind him I saw this what this lady
start crying and I was like what
happened well later on she told me that
he'd been struggling with this he had
never told anyone and so it was like the
greatest revelation and she went home
and he went home and told his mom that
he was dyslexic like Alton and so to be
able to use that is like but if I don't
put it out there and and I'm okay
you know we I'll always be dyslexic but
doesn't mean I'm dumb it doesn't mean
I'm stupid I get to decide who I am this
also speaks so highly of the see it
being that when when that when that girl
that that was you know you you turned
out okay I don't believe that story well
that now that she's seen an example of
someone that has went through that story
and turned out okay then now that's a
new paradigm of thinking and we wonder
how often that in same thing with the
one the kid that stands up he was before
it was a fourth I'm Dyslexic to telling
everyone revealing that about us after
struggling with it huh so how many
untappd in opportunities exist for
people to have their paradigms of
thinking changed or for them to be able
to come out and feel like they're
expressing themselves more fully in the
world and those untapped opportunities
can be tapped into by having people like
you go and authentically share your
experiences so it in a sense it's almost
like the more authentic sharing that we
have about our journeys and the decks of
cards that we were dealt and how we
overcame them like the more that we have
people like you that have different all
these different blueprints that they
grew up with sharing the more that we
can tap into those opportunities I think
the adults I mean in our society today I
think we've we've done nothing but
taught kids how to be fake what I mean
by that is we talked about how we don't
have any problems you know everything is
great if you do have problems you keep
them to yourself and and I understand
some of that but again it's we rob
people of the opportunity to see what
it's like to heal so here's an example
my family when people somebody died or
tragic tragedy happened people fought or
they got drunk so that's all I saw
I and so when I went to school I went to
elementary school and I never saw any
problems my teachers had because they
kept it to themselves and they wanted to
appear to be strong so one of the
phrases I say all the time is the most
important thing in life is to be sincere
when you agree yes what you're doing
once you learn how to fake that you've
got it made so we spent a whole bunch of
time trying to make people think that we
have it all together but really we don't
you know and it's okay if I don't happen
together today I show up I run an
al-anon Mike Allen I'm not doing very
good and you give me some advice or or
just even being with your feelings and
just yeah holding space for you that
yeah but if I walk around and act like
I'm perfect what happens is
that it's like I start to lose myself
like I got to put on this front and so
again then we rob people the opportunity
to see what it's like to heal so I
needed to watch growing up as a child I
needed to watch a teacher fall apart and
then pull themselves back together to
have a bad day instead of just being a
great teacher no problems so but I got
robbed at that opportunity because a lot
of people wanted to appear to be strong
let's stick on the importance of
especially men becoming more emotionally
intelligent becoming more vulnerable
becoming more able to express themselves
by holding space for other men or for
other women and how that actually
translates to being a better spouse to
being a better father to being a better
coworker to being more empathetic to be
more collaborative tell us about that
so for me like the discovery I think
part of it is it's like you don't know
where it's gonna take you and for men we
want to appear to be strong and so
there's this confusion that if you're
like me and you like taking taking
pictures of flowers or writing poetry is
that strong and so but I think I sure
think so yeah Society teaches us that's
not the way it's supposed to be why is
this guy posting flowers and poems but
the other part is will I'm robbing
myself and then again essentially I'm
miserable because I'm not being Who I am
and I'm this emotional on this emotional
guy and if I rob that what happens is I
invest what happens more often than not
is we invest all our emotions in the
wrong one so if I suppress this emotion
of being emotional or sensitive it all
goes into anger and frustration and to
me I see a lot of a lot of us men we
struggle with that
being empathetic or showing emotion
because we want to appear tough and we
don't want to be weak and you know what
we are weak sometimes and that's okay
yes so a paradigm change towards making
it cool for men to have flowers and
their news feeds or poems in their news
feeds or for them to hold space for the
emotional or conscious evolution of
other for other people that while
simultaneously having some sort of like
a balance with their desire to be strong
- which is totally cool and same thing
with women the balance of being strong
with being emotionally available and
resilient okay let's talk about how
there are right and wrong things to say
with people that have their different
cards that they're being dealt in life
and also how you know you have this
beautiful way of putting it you have to
love people where they're at versus
focusing on their circumstances teachers
about this so example like if I take
group of kids to serve on a mission trip
that's one of the things that we talk
about is fall in love with with people
get to know them don't look at their
circumstance and let that dictate how
you're going to treat them we need to
treat everybody with respect and I think
we need to have this conversation where
we're looking people I died not down on
them
we've had some great interactions with
adults who were homeless some of the
most authentic uplifting teaching
moments and you think well how in the
world can someone homeless inspire me so
one of the trips we went on one of the
homeless lady told one of our girls she
was pouring her some water
and so the homeless lady said don't you
ever let me catch you doing that in a
bar and she said you need to be rocking
walking the runway or being the
President of the United States and my
girl who came from a upper-middle class
home her response was
I'm not that smart and the lady got
upset she goes don't you ever say that
about yourself and so if you don't put
yourself in a position to listen to
people we we've never would have got
that advice and to this day that girl
says I was the best piece of advice
she's ever gotten because it came from
somebody that she felt like was being
real and so but it's lessons like that
where you get to meet people and and
again love them where they're at not
well you're homeless or you're rich or
you're poor you're black or white if we
just erase all that and get to know
people to me that's that's where you
learn damn sometimes the the advice or
these reflections that we're getting
from our family members about our own
like personal development and journeys
don't really land because they're coming
from the people that are closest to us
but when they come from someone that's
real that's like this you know this
third party that maybe you're not
engaging with too often but that comes
up and then drop something like don't
you ever not love yourself like that
don't you ever not believe in yourself
like that yeah yeah yeah and then you
know there's lots of things we tell
people like especially with dealing with
children you know if we go visit a
children's home you you you don't tell
them you're gonna come back if you're
not gonna come back because they're used
to that they're used to people and so
the other thing we talk about is when I
take my kids to use our mission trip or
a nursing home don't look at people like
their zoo animals you know go have a
conversation and I remember that so when
I was at the Boys Ranch our ranch dad
would stay just outside playing you know
like we were happy kids or get this are
you ready Perkins used to have a parade
and every year we rode on the back of
that trailer that said Oklahoma Lions
boys right so we felt like zoo animals
and so people really didn't it's like
they didn't know what to say they forgot
that we were children and so we want to
have a conversation I want to have a
calm
station with everybody I don't care how
different you are another thing you
don't tell people like if somebody's in
a like my mom was a drug addict I had
lots of people say this to me all the
time you you well they just say do you
want to turn out like your mom well of
course I don't of course I don't but I
don't need you to tell me that I don't
we can you would be like motivation yeah
you thought it was motivation and and
what happens is it just makes me not
like you because yeah my mom was a drug
addict but that was my mother and so for
me it's how do you have this
conversation where you lead people to
tell themselves I don't want to be a
drug addict so that's the end it's not
so much about like my mom it's I don't
want to be a drug addict so you know
there's lots of things like that what we
want to talk about helping people think
through the process instead of just
telling them what to do questions are so
powerful for that absolutely we'll think
about this when you look at kids in the
system they're forced to go to
counseling which some of them need
counseling and they need therapy but
here's the thing that's missing nobody's
asking them hey can I can I help treat
you they're forced to go and I realize
as a kid being forced to go to
counseling nobody ever said Altan can I
help you I was forced to sit down and
people crammed questions down my throat
and I felt like I didn't have any power
well if you give me the power then I
understand that I can change and
overcome whatever I'm in your office for
does that make sense yeah and so nobody
ever asks can I help you it was just
forced upon me
what would the optimal dialogue look
like between a counselor or any types of
like human services that may be trying
to help or even just like a mentor to an
editor yeah yeah well just ask them
questions so here's an example I was in
Oakland California visiting a prison and
I sat down with a kid who was in there
for murder twelve-year-old kid in there
for murder so we were having a
conversation about his family so instead
of
degrading him I'd say I'd ask him
questions like so where's your where's
your dad and he'd say he's in the prison
across town and then I'd say well who
would you call if you needed something
since your dad's in prison he'd say well
I can call my dad he's in prison I'd
call my dad and I was like explain that
to me and the kid would think through
and he goes oh yeah that didn't make any
sense he's all instead of telling them
how stupid it is let them figure out
through them you know by themselves by
asking questions but all too often I
think we want to give them the answer
and you don't allow people to think you
know let me help you sift through it and
so that internal dialogue if we can help
people create an internal dialogue about
their issues about their insecurities I
think that's how you come out on the
other side and it's by asking questions
asking the right questions asking
questions that facilitate internal
dialogue towards realization and towards
repairing to not repeat that's a really
good stuff that's such a in the sense
it's a lot of what we do here on the
show we ask questions and we hope that
the guest shines that their best passing
along transmitting this these great
stories or wisdom tell their people that
then get to do something like also take
what is being transmitted and further
build on it ask more questions about it
have more internal dialogues or creative
processes about it right now all these
different things that you've been
teaching throughout our conversation
that these these blueprints for healing
or that we have to repair so we don't
repeat or how we can ask these questions
for internal dialogues to happen
that can transform people there's so
much richness present right here in
those concepts that can be built on even
further I I'm just I'm so curious as to
how we asked questions like this example
that you gave in the prison with the 12
year old that's in there for murder that
gets him to further realize that you're
again you're not giving an answer you're
asking questions that get him to realize
how ridiculous that think that logical
thinking process was and even if he
didn't get it
right then it's I hope that he'll get it
so sometimes you ask a question and they
don't get it till later on but if you
don't ask the question they may never
get it or if you tell them they reject
it right off the bat yeah yeah and so
here's here's an example of this
internal dialogue so one of the
statements my mom said to me that was
like I struggled for years that she said
to me that sent me back so my mom said
one time that the only reason why I was
successful or I made it is because god
bless me more than the rest of us she
said god blessed you more than the rest
of my children and so that was tough
now if I didn't think about why she said
that I would just be bitter I mean cuz
you think why in the world would a mom
ever say that to her child
and that wasn't good enough for me I
wanted to know why and so if you don't
cycle through that then you just arrived
that there's no good reason then you're
bitter so here's what I figured out I
think my mom sort of resented me because
that I was the only one of her children
that made it out now here's the other
part the rest of them stayed home I got
taken away and so my mom every time she
looked at me she couldn't take credit
for the way I turned out and so that's
why she said that
and so once I arrived at that was that's
what I thought was the issue it made
sense and I could let it go but if I
didn't think about and cycle through
that process and come up with something
it's unresolved issue that morphs into
something else so I take that issue and
now I'm bitter my mom and my mom's dead
and so now I take it out on someone else
so it was important for me to work
through that you had an internal
dialogue with yourself that helped you
repair so that you didn't repeat yes it
helps you heal there's an aspect to what
you do that also helps people check
their privilege I want us to talk about
that it's a touchy subject there's
there's a lot of people that don't like
to have their privilege pointed out and
and it's tough to figure out what
percentage of has to do with someone's
hard work has to do with them having a
head start you know if you have two
parents and both your parents are
college-educated and you grew up in a
house that always had food and water and
love and I mean that kind of make sense
to people they're like okay that makes
sense versus if I'm constantly if I
don't know my mom and dad if I was moved
between foster care center as if etc so
speak about that so we to me when you
talk about privilege I look at it kind
of as a different way so privilege is
like something that you get to do like
you get the privilege to drive our car
or stay up past a curfew and so some of
those privileges are based off of where
you come from so if you look at a family
that came from a lot of money they tend
to be privileged and and so to me it's
not necessarily or always negative to me
the issue comes with what do you do with
it so I look at people who don't have
anything but maybe advice to offer if
you're keeping it to yourself that's
just as bad as somebody who has lots of
money that may not be using it to help
people
I think we all have privileges that are
meant to help people but you do and I
think sometimes people use their
privilege to gain an advantage
yeah like market advantage absolutely or
or honestly sometimes to keep people
down and so for me it's it's not that I
want to go head to head with those
people I'm not about arguing or fighting
what I want to do is show people that
there's a better way so I came from
absolutely nothing and a my privilege
yeah to some people yes I am privileged
but how am I using it how am I using
what's been given to me that right to
share my story that you know I felt like
I was given a deck of cards that was
horrible that turned into a privilege
that I can use to help other people so
it's again it's kind of perspective
that's not always easy sometimes it's
not easy being a may sound crazy it's
not easy being a rich kid it's not easy
being a poor kid sometimes but it's what
you do with it and and so whoa okay so
at one side of the of this like bell
curve of socioeconomic status or it's
not even it's a well it might be maybe
actually both a a a bell curve and a
power-law distribution and on on the on
the heavy rich side on the socioeconomic
status are you taking the the privilege
that you have and are you reshaping
rules and regulations to propagate your
own privilege or are you doing things
like truly giving and feeling how
godlike it feels like when you can
uplift other people that have abuse or
neglect or whatnot and help them
creatively realize themselves in this
world and then and that's where some of
the that like you said that
when you are wealthy that at times it
can be really hard when maybe your
parents constantly have security teams
around them and then you don't know if
people love you for who you are or for
your parents all these types of things
and then on the other end on I actually
really liked how you gave this because
actually did this example because it
actually ties us into what we were
talking about throughout which was this
these uncie's opportunities untapped
into opportunities that if you have come
from a rougher socioeconomic status that
you have so much potential to share how
you've overcome or persevered through a
card that was dealt to you that ended up
being a lesson that you repaired so you
didn't repeat and that it's literally
you holding that to yourself doesn't
actually help other people it helps when
you share that gift how you've overcome
that and persevered I like that one a
lot too that that's so that's actually a
privilege to that sometimes we don't we
don't share that gift and then that that
but it can be seen as a privilege when
we do share that gift and when it does
help other people just like when we
share our excess amounts of money with
other people well you know we look at
sharing trades on YouTube and videos all
the time that's how people learn in this
day and age technology Twitter Instagram
and so it don't you think it's funny
that you can find a YouTube video on how
to do everything but he'll yeah I mean
think about that it's but it's because
we keep it to ourselves and we keep it
to ourselves because we don't want to
appear to be broken mm-hmm
and so if we can put it out there you
know if we can put it out there that hey
I'm broken but I'm gonna put myself back
together someone else will go man I can
I think I can do that I think I can do
that and again it's not that I'm great I
don't think I'm any better than anyone
else but one of the most rewarding
things ever is it's it when a kid comes
up in
I think I can do it because you did it
that's just one of the most rewarding
things in the entire world and what
usually it's it's stuff that I can
graduate from high school it's I don't
have to be abusive like my dad I I get
letters and mails and emails all the
times where kids tell me stuff that they
never shared with anyone else and it is
absolutely priceless
to know that my crazy story matters to a
kid that's struggling because who knows
maybe that kids at the end of their rope
and if I keep that to myself to myself
they may they may feel alone who knows
when the next one the next not Alton but
the next person willing to share it
comes along and I think we're all broken
in some some way so one of one of my
quotes that I talked about I got from a
movie and it was a boxtrolls I don't
know if you ever watch that but this
little cartoon but in this movie it said
sometimes when a heart is broke and it
grows back crooked and so there's two
parts of that number one a heart grew
back crooked it's still together and
it's beating and it's in it's thriving
and it may be different but it's still
working
it's the hearts that don't grow back
together and so that's when I look at
like my brother or my sister or my other
brother that I felt like their heart
never grew back
now I had a conversation with my brother
my oldest brother about did you ever
have anyone any adult that you felt like
really mattered and cared enough about
you to help your heart he only said no
and on the other hand I did and so I
look at like people who grew up in
different places so if you grew up with
two parents and life was great sometimes
people say I can't relate to you there's
nothing I can teach you that's not true
I can watch you and learn how to be
normal I mean I can watch your family
function and at least I can get those
aspects and those tools and and some of
that stuff
learn how to be if nothing else a good
son or good husband by watching people
who come from a good home so it's not
about having a story like mine just the
fact that we're different we all have
something to learn that I'm hoping
people look at me and go you know what
if I'm kind to a third grader that kid
might graduate from high school if I
believe in them that may be the one
thing that they need to believe in
themselves and so it's not you know so
that's what I'm hoping that people can
look at that and in and gain lots of
listen to my story and say hey man if we
just believe in people maybe that'll
help speaks so highly of to see it be it
mentality in essence that is so
necessary and you're giving these
examples of us becoming more vulnerable
and sharing our stories and our journeys
on YouTube or on other social platforms
and what will enable other people to do
is to see that look like first of all
people aren't perfect like in so many
ways and a lot of the platforms portray
especially Instagram G's and if we maybe
post something about our own conscious
evolution or personal development and
transformation then it can elicit other
people to feel comfortable with saying
hey they're talking about a card that
they were dealt that wasn't that good or
a couple cards that they were dealt that
wasn't one that good but that they
learned how to love those cards and they
learned how to repair themselves and to
not repeat the mistakes and that's
beautiful I I have as a video on the
channel of me talking about the four
months that I spent in jail because I
went for cannabis and you know there's
videos on our channel as well of
interviewing different leaders in their
fields when they talk about you know a
different cycle therapies like
psychedelic psychotherapy there's
different styles now and for best
practices of ways to
to to integrate these cards that have
been dealt and feel really comfortable
with talking about them and and healing
and making healing cool and maybe making
it popular so you have more young people
that feel like they can walk in Alan's
shoes and go out and and give these
examples where they give talks about
what cards they were dealt and how they
persevered and overcame them okay I feel
as though we have so much to still talk
about will you talk to us about that
those of those you know that moment
specifically for you and the judge told
your mom that she wasn't fit to be a
mother and that you were like that's
never happening to me as a father then
you found someone that you were in love
with and we're able to have two children
with and then you went and adopted three
other children two years ago tell us
about your relationship with family and
your relationship with your children and
how that's just in one generation you
were able to go from you know your
mother your father's be all being gone
mother in the circumcenter says she had
four of your other siblings not being
able to persevere but you being able to
and now all five of the ones that you
have now able to persevere in one
generation have that massive familial
lineage transition is huge it's huge oh
and it's gorgeous and talk to us well so
my relationship with my kids and my
family is it perfect
no it's not perfect but it was it was a
process so you go from thinking or
wanting to be the world's greatest dad
and having people say that and not
feeling like that on the inside so what
people would tell me man you're the
world's greatest dad it had the exact
opposite because I knew I didn't know
what to compare
and I thought I was getting it even that
I was getting it all wrong you know I
felt like that I felt like no matter
what I did my kids I was gonna
disappoint them and I wasn't gonna be
good enough and so I had a couple of
things that taught me what was most
important so it wasn't by the stuff you
know I went through that process where
you thought man if you buy your kids
everything that's it what I found is
that the greatest the greatest thing
ever is time with my children mm-hmm and
and it's doing stuff that they want to
do you know it's not hey I'm going
fishing you want to go and then I'll
call that quality time what about me
doing what they want to do and and so
that's what I've learned as being a
father and so also you have to be
willing to be taught by your children so
my kids sometimes said some of the most
hurtful stuff that was true like
somebody one time you know I just gotten
on to my son I think I was probably a
little over the top getting on to him a
few minutes later running into somebody
and here's what they said man
Kelton you got a great pad you got a
great dad now this is a few minutes
later earlier I was chewing him out and
so when we got in a car here's what my
son said to me I wish I had that dad
that they were talking about and it it
hurt but he was telling the truth
and so that's that process if I really
want to be a good dad be be be that and
it's tough I mean I make mistakes I get
it wrong but man I'm telling you that my
children are my heart and soul that is
my motivation to get up every day to to
go to work to share my story for them to
be proud of me you know I always talked
about how you know when I'm on my last
few days of life I want my children's
and we're proud of you over anyone else
I mean I want other people to say but I
want my kids to say you weren't perfect
dad but we're proud of it and I think if
you go with that that's it so we have
this conversation on what's the
difference between being a good man and
a
that there isn't one if you're a good
man you're a good dad if you're a good
dad you're a good man there's there's no
separate and so sometimes same thing
with mums absolutely but we struggle
with that and being a good dad doesn't
mean you're good all the time but when
you're bad let your child see you fix it
and that's what makes you a good dad
yeah well you have the way that we can
optimally communicate wisdom from our
grandparents are at the latter end of
their life and they're trying to
communicate wisdom down to the youngest
as well as how the youngest are able to
kind of be at like this like edge of
curiosity in childhood and playing with
the newest technologies and whatnot
maybe they can also help communicate up
to the parents and to the grandparents
as well so there's this like
transmission of wisdom and knowledge
that happens between the youngest to the
oldest oldest the youngest and to be
open-minded to that yeah there's so
there's so much there's so much here
yeah oh I was like my six-year-old yeah
Curtis that we adopted heat so like we
talked about being present and it's a
struggle than today's age what does it
mean to be present yeah if I'm sitting
on the couch and you're on your phone
that's to me that's not what it means to
be President so president is engaged so
here's an example about getting it wrong
so he was telling me a story my
six-year-old now six-year-old he goes on
and on and it's just full of words and I
don't know where his story is going so I
check out about after 30 seconds and I
get on my phone and he's talking I'm on
my phone all of a sudden I don't hear
anything I'm like go ahead Curtis go
ahead and he goes it's all right I'll
wait till you're done said I mean it's
like what he was saying was that I know
right now I'm
important in our wait till I'm important
again and my goal is to not miss those
opportunities because I mean I can't get
that moment back and that may have been
that may have been when he was wanting
to share something or connect with me
when he needed it most and so it could
also be a bunch of blahblah he that's
not as that important so it's almost as
though like how do we parse those
moments for when we want to most
critically listen to our six-year-olds
telling stories because there could be
really important moments of being
present or for learnings for us but also
that we could potentially be helping
spread our ideas around the world by
route maybe rather than engaging in that
story with the with our own genetics
with our own offspring for a period of
time maybe it is more effective for us
to be engaging with the world and
spreading memes that way maybe there is
someone that if you were to just had you
know made that caller sent that message
or engaged on that social post or
whatever it was that maybe there were
two or five or ten kids that could have
seen something that could have altered
their trajectory so it's kind of this
like how do we figure out those moments
and what to do also it's important for
us to mention that all of this has your
story has so much to do with the
importance of what children experience
from the moment that they're born so
that whatever inputs children are taking
into their spirit once they're born into
the world if parents weren't ready to
have children if they weren't
financially ready if they weren't able
to provide the child with love or
compassion or water food shelter or any
of these basic needs that the child
needs these are kind of like the roots
of the tree of the child and that the
only way for the tree to have its own
unique creative expression of
roots happen into the world for the
gifts to happen that all of those
nutrients need to be in place in their
root systems and the the the rapid miss
that neural architecture gets laid out
in the brain from zero to two is just so
fast and that it's so evident that that
it's actually it's you're like you are
miracle in so many ways you are because
and it's really it's really important
for us to recognize that parents being
ready and having more optimal
circumstances for their children being
brought into the world is exactly what's
needed for their children to have more
opportune life trajectories than when in
many ways like that your other siblings
you know weren't able to have yeah and I
think like said I made it or I overcame
because people started feeding that tree
mm-hmm and it wasn't just one person it
wasn't just one person one of my
all-time favorite projects I do with
teachers as I give them sticky notes and
I have them right if they could give a
message to a child what would it be so
imagine you do this with 300 teachers so
I give them a sticky note and then I
have them come stick it on the wall so
at the end of that what I'll do is I'll
go let's say Alton comes into your
school and I'm a foster kid
my mom's a drug addict and I come into
your school and I walk down the hallway
and I run into Miss Johnson who says and
I take the sticky note and I stick it to
myself and it says you are somebody I
love you you're awesome and I walk
around for a few minutes with those
sticky notes and I think that's what
happened I think I had enough of those
that I made it and imagine if you don't
get those you know how do you how do you
how do you do something that you've
never seen how do you give somebody
something you don't have and so I
learned how to
not only love other people but love
myself because I watched other people do
that I had people say amazing things to
me that I sort of rejected in the
beginning but later on again in life
they showed up and they made sense I
love that one
this is the little like sticky notes of
wisdom that people could be passing
along to others and we kind of like grab
them and if we wear them long enough we
can feel that light and love that was
initially brought to those notes in that
if we are missing any of those nutrients
and the flourishing of our gifts that if
we get enough of those little pieces of
light and love that come into our life
that they can kind of fill some of those
spot enos in the in the nutrient
deprivation in the root systems and then
the gifts can come into the world well
yeah well imagine if just one teacher
shared I mean that's important but if
300 teachers if a kid goes up to the
school and then one day he runs into ten
teachers that say something nice to him
he's gonna like school he's gonna like
school he's gonna like education he's
gonna want to learn he's gonna feel
loved and then he walks out the door it
goes to maybe a place that's full of
misery but if nothing else here's what
we've done we've taught him the
difference see what I mean and if you
don't share that that word of
encouragement that's robbing people of
sometimes that opportunity to grow or to
and it could be a simple you look nice
today or glad to see you or handshake
and sometimes that matters yeah yeah the
tiniest butterfly effects of positivity
and light um let's have him talk about
the relationship of you mentioned this a
couple times throughout but that diesel
visa what was brought forth to you as
maybe light or love through different
people it kind of at times it felt like
was there kind of bringing forth some
light or some love through different
people into your life to help your
trajectory what's been your relationship
with God or sorcerer tell us about that
so it's interesting so one of my
struggles is that my abusive ranch dad
was a deacon in a church and so that was
a struggle and it kind of soured me
really with faith and so here's here's
another issue people don't think about
people often refer to God as father wow
you think that made me feel so I listen
to people say God will never let
anything bad happen to you that didn't
make any sense to me I mean my mom's a
drug addict I don't know who my dad is
I've been beat with everything and so
when people would say God will never let
anything bad happen to you I thought God
forgot about me mm-hmm
that's what I thought and honestly my
relationship with God only became what
it is today is because people who loved
God loved me people who said that they
loved God started loving me and that's
what made sense and so honestly I didn't
see God I felt like he abandoned me I
was looking for him but I felt like he
was either hiding or running for me and
he had forgotten about me and when I saw
these people going to church who wasn't
trying to cram religion down my throat
loved me for who I was like the church
that I go to now first United Methodist
Church in Stillwater unconditional love
and it's not about me being a youth
director it's not about me being an
author it's about me being family their
church family and that's how I think we
should approach people it's not about
denomination it's not about my faith
being stronger than yours it's about if
I say God how about I do what I say and
I'm going to love you even if you're
different and so that that's what turned
my faith around and so you know to me
it's a I'm constantly thinking you know
I hear people say I heard from God I'm
100 percent well I can say this I'm not
a hundred percent sure that I've ever
heard God tell me something specifically
to do however
I know what I'm a hundred percent sure I
know what God wants me to do love you
and love everybody else and if you get
that part right and it's not always easy
don't get me wrong but serve people you
know find ways to help people and
children and elderly people and you know
get yourself involved and that that's
what we should be doing and it's not
that complicated so yeah what do you
think is the relationship between the
amount of free will that we have you
know that that's interesting and I'm not
sure I have an answer for free will I
believe that God gives us free will to
make our choices and so like this
predestined it it gets complicated to
explain I think God allows me to make
choices I run into like when you look at
the bad stuff that happens so like
people say it's predestined I would
argue that I do not believe that God
wants people to hurt people so if you
say life's predestined so how do you
explain a child molester
I mean God predestined for that kid to
be molested you know what I mean and so
to me it gets tricky so I think that's
just where we get it wrong in my opinion
I think people are hurting and broken
and they just do bad stuff and so
predestined in terms of choices does God
make it easier no I think God gives us
everything we need to be who we should
be and who he wants us to be and we get
to choose so to me that's the kind of
the way the way I look at it does it
feel like our spirit comes from God or
from that source or from that all that
is into these into meeting these bodies
for these
since oh absolutely absolutely and again
it's perspective if you don't know where
it's coming from you might not use it in
the right way you know I mean if you
don't know where that's and that would
be marked meaning if you don't know that
that that whisper that spirit or that
that that hope that's coming to you if
you don't know where that's coming from
sometimes I think it's tricky and so for
me it's understanding where my source my
my strength my encouragement comes from
and when I don't feel it this is why
it's important for us to be active in
help that maybe you can remind me that
it's still there
does that make sense so but when when I
lose it that's when we should show up
and so because there are times that
again I feel like either inside my own
head that maybe I'm not good enough
where I'm getting it wrong and almost
always the right person shows up yeah
and and part of that's because I'm
looking for it so versus looking for
somebody that's gonna pour negativity in
me and then what about for young people
and adults that are still identifying
like what maybe their divine purposes in
the world what their gift is in the
world what would you recommend for
people so that that's another
interesting one of the churches I went
to a long time ago they did this study
called a Purpose Driven Life and so it
confused me because I thought we all
have one purpose and how do I know what
my purpose is so if I'm homeless
am i worthless if I you know and so that
I struggled with that so to me when you
look at purpose office I was talking to
a mom in our church and she was talking
about how she didn't know what her
purpose was and I said there's a purpose
and you being a mom that's one of the
most important things and she didn't
look at it that way there's a purpose
and me being a dad there's a purpose and
you being a son
there's a purpose it and so for me
sometimes your purpose change sometimes
your purpose it's evolving I think you
know my purpose was to be here and do
this interview tomorrow it's gonna be
you know to speak at that at that
professional summit so it's not about in
my opinion one specific thing it's about
one purpose to the next one purpose to
the next not one big big big purpose mmm
interesting since like you can divide
your maybe your life purpose you're in
North Star etc into a bunch of micro
experiences and purposes absolutely I
like that yeah instead of one big one I
think it's just it's one step at a time
and every one of those micro purposes
cascades a butterfly effect out and
impacts people positively absolutely and
then maybe at the end there is sort of
this like grand calculation that you can
see of what you've done in your
contribution to the interconnectedness
of everything I like that I like that
the micro purpose since I don't I don't
want to paint myself into a box I mean
if you think here's my example if your
purpose is to play professional football
what happens when you blow your knee
well I'm not playing professional
football anymore my purpose is over well
we see that happen more often than not
well maybe now my purpose is to get
involved and do something else or my
purpose may be to have a conversation
with a football player that's struggling
with addiction or something else and so
to me it's purposes it's those little
little bitty things as well as the big
ones I like that a lot
for identifying meaning in life and
seeing it as micro purposes along the
journey and the impact that that has on
other people along the way so what about
then with we're approaching this
exponential technology age I mean your
children have at their fingertips more
power than ever before and their
children will have the same thing as
there's going to continue happening what
are some of the most important
principles that you think children and
adults can embody going into this
exponential technology age you know my
first gut answer is that life is about
relationships that if we can work on
building relationships face-to-face with
people that's that's what's important
because we can get lost in that and I
think if we can continue building
relationships and and and and instilling
that we care about each other and and
that's what I hope even through this
technology and that's what we lose I
mean I can get on Twitter Instagram and
post anything that whatever I want make
my life look as great or as bad as I
want to and and there's no relationship
in a communication with Twitter and so
having these face-to-face conversations
and and working on the hard stuff that
that's what makes that relationship
strong so that's what I hope that we go
back to at some point that we can go
back to making sure that relationships
are at the the forefront of our our
thought instead of just sending messages
and in you know faces and all these
things that you know smiling faces and
whatever just to get our expression
across and not you know they're
effective but we lose that and then what
about on a geopolitical level that
there's eight billion of us now there's
a lot of humans there's more and more
growing democratization of these
exponential technologies whatever maybe
what would you say is maybe a core thing
that we can do around the world
helped bring us closer together towards
that unity so well let's let's take that
technology and use it for education in
in purposes than where we can help each
other and and I see a lot of it getting
twisted you know we talked about you
know in the car ride about how people
they want to channel things and make it
look a certain way and if we know what's
wrong let's stand up and and not take
part in whether we're bad-mouthing
people and so you know when you look at
technology let's use that in a way to
educate people let's shoot videos that
show people healing let's shoot videos
of people who are hungry so we know we
have to feed them and so that's what to
me that's what I think we should use
technology for or if we can guide more
to that helping people yeah that's great
leveraged exponential technology for
helping people for healing for education
and they'll get us closer to that unity
a lot of indigenous leaders around the
world are saying that our disconnection
from nature from source from God is the
reason why we have so many of the issues
that we have in our world how do you
feel about that so here here's my
example I would agree I think we
technology has taken us away from
relationship with people and in God I
really think it has and so Tim well I
went to Bolivia went on a mission trip
to Bolivia and my goal I thought was I'm
gonna teach these people about God know
I live in the city I got cell phone so
we pack up we go to Bolivia I'm up in
the middle of nowhere high altitude and
my job as I'm supposed to play with the
kids and then help pour the cement floor
but I want to teach these people about
God well what happens when you get there
and those people already know about God
yeah
it was the most eye-opening experience
ever damn what did they how would it be
how did they express that there we also
I figured it out real quick I figured it
out real quick when you listened talk
yeah so what were they saying that made
you well because their life was centered
around unity yeah
together so like in this village there
may have been two hundred people in this
village and what was interesting is that
I got to see what true unity looked like
so there was a baby that passed away and
people walked for days to celebrate life
so we get upset and cry and an emotional
which rightly so but they celebrate life
when the baby passed away but people
walked for days to come be together when
they build like every one of the houses
had like these mud fences so anytime
somebody built a built a fence the whole
village came and helped to do that and
then you talk about what his happy look
like those people were happy they didn't
have technology they didn't have
cellphones they didn't have to worry
about what was happening really on this
you know on the other side of the world
about the stock market they had
everything they need they pitched in
they did it together and it was it was a
great lesson in the heart the hard part
is sometimes we become complacent you
know I go to Bolivia and I experienced
that in its eye opening and then I come
back to United States and I'm on fire
and I'm changed and then it slowly
starts to chip away and so that's the
hard part but up there in Bolivia they
didn't have all that stuff and those
people loved God they loved connecting
and being together it makes me in so
many ways kind of in a sense question
what's going on with productivity in
this economic machinery and what are we
building all this for and if I can't
take moments of my time to just slow
down and just be and
be in nature and be with family and go
on like a couple day walk just to be
with other humans to help them build
fence etcetera with their homes this
these types of things then what is the
point of the speed at which we're moving
so fast and in so many ways having so
many mental health or stress issues or
there's like this weird situation that's
happening with the speed of the economic
machinery with the same time that were
feeling that disconnection from nature
that disconnection from source from God
and when you slow down and you look at
that divine nature in other people you
feel it right there does it ever feel
like we're in a simulation so III think
it seems like the world sometimes can be
that way personally I mean there are
moments in life where I feel like that's
happening the other part the reason why
I think people don't slow down it's
sometimes if you slow down you have to
self-reflect and you just it's easier to
keep going it's easy to keep going
something I think that's why a lot of
times people don't slow down I mean I've
been that way where I've been so busy
that if I stop then I I may have to
think or I may have to deal with some
issues that I don't want to deal with so
I just keep running so I have this weird
analogy of what it's like to
self-reflect so imagine you have a car
and your car is smoking and we've all
seen that car driving down the street
right but smoke coming out of the back
of it well the cars driving smokes
coming out of the back of it and you're
you don't care cuz smokes not getting
inside your car well guess what happens
when you come to the stop sign
eventually that smoke starts to come
inside and you recognize that there's a
problem but instead of turning and going
to the gas station or the mechanic and
getting your car fix what do we do
step on the gas and start moving again
so as long as I'm moving gas is not
coming in the car but the minute I stop
and so this is this is my point
that every once in a while we need to
stop and not get choked out by the smoke
but we get enough smoke or we
self-reflect or we be still long enough
that we realize that we have a problem
that we've got to get it fixed and so
that's why I think people keep moving
so that's such a beautiful ecology the
economical scenery is making us move and
just keep pushing on the gas every time
we get to a stop sign instead of slowing
dot that's knob sign engaging on that
self-reflective process of who am i what
am I doing here these deepest questions
of life what how how can I engage with
my family more my purpose more last
question what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world
hmm my first purse is a parents love for
their children I think to me that is
just the the greatest I'm in both ways I
mean all my kids that are adopted
they're my kids it to like it's to me
they've always been my kids and so
watching not only me love them let them
love me is like the greatest thing ever
that some kids could love me you know
when we when our kids when we adopted
the three you know we had the judge
asked our three children would you like
to adopt Kristen and Alton and Kelton
and Colin we wanted them to have a part
so to me that just a a a family love a
love from a stranger to another stranger
unconditional love that's not
judgemental that's not
critical and so to me that's what it is
and part of I think why we missed that
is for the longest time I didn't love
myself and I believe it's impossible to
love someone else truly love someone
else if you don't love yourself and so
when you when I work what is love that's
when you can walk side by side you can
help people you can be in the presence
of people without judgment without
criticism without looking down on them
so that's that's what I'm talking about
and so with my family I feel like that
that's it so Alton this has been such a
beautiful conversation thank you for
joining us on the show appreciate it
thanks for having me so enriching I
think we covered just gorgeous array of
topics that and metaphors and your
perspective has been so fun to
understand more and share with the world
so thank you thank you thank you thank
you appreciate it
like humid thank you alrighty it's been
awesome yeah I was looking forward to
this you're so awesome or you are so
incredible one I highly recommend
everyone to check out the links in the
bio below we greatly appreciate you
tuning in to this episode thank you
everyone again the links in the bar
below again that's Alan Carter dotnet
also his Twitter profile also check out
the book links check out those books and
share them with more people have more
conversations to your friends your
families co-workers people online on
social media about what we talked about
in this episode about these blueprints
for healing and about these blueprints
for choice and about love and how to
build a better future all together I'll
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders the organizations
around the world do you believe and
support them and help them grow support
Elton's organizations support ours as
well sports simulation all the links are
below
you can find us PayPal patreon
cryptocurrency consign coal merchant get
paid all those links are below and also
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in we will see you soon
there it is what it is
thanks man appreciate it about fun out
of fun so I hope you got some good stuff
here soon
beyond unique and you are wise for the
level of complex cards that you were
adult it's beautiful the way you're
sharing and inspiring other people to
share I'm so grateful this opportunity
happened and I hope that we ripple out
and an impact a lot of other people
positively